cette année j'ai l'honneur d'être
l'ambassadeur de la cause du traumatisme
cranio-cérébral les tissus si vous avez
reconnu nicolas tu connais auteur
compositeur interprète kiwi ambassadeur
pour la cause du traumatisme crânio
cérébral qu'on peut dire tcc d'ailleurs
après le grave accident de voiture qu'il
a eue en 2018 on ne reçoit ce matin
nicolas ciccone bonjour bonjour ça va
bien très bien et vous dix-huit mois
après un grave accident de voiture dans
lequel vous avez frôlé la mort c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que vous êtes
porte-parole pour la cause comment ça va
mal ça sera obligé j'étais assez
chanceux malgré la commotion cérébrale à
m'en remettre
donc je suis vraiment chanceux aussi
malheureusement pas le cas d'à peu près
du tiers des gens qui ont une commotion
cérébrale qui ne s'en remettra jamais
c'est vraiment un choc qui dure pour la
plupart donc de mon côté ça va bien bon
mais tant mieux je suis heureuse de vous
entendre dire ça parce qu'un traumatisme
crânio cérébral en fait c'est comme une
grosse commotion cérébrale sévère qui
peut nous accompagner toute la vie avec
des séquelles assez importante
oui c'est sûr que le cerveau reste
quelque chose d'abstrait donc potes de
commotions cérébrales qui sont
identiques mais ça l'est des séquelles
importantes par rapport sur la mémoire
sur la luminosité sur la vue sur les
mots tête puis c'est important de
préciser que deux tiers des gens dont 65
% des gens qui ont une formation ne
retourneront jamais travaillé c'est
vraiment un choc qui disent qu'ils vont
affecter pas juste la personne mais
aussi l'entourage
dames 1 parce que quand on est en couple
avec quelqu'un qui a été ccb faut s'en
occuper
qu'on soit un enfant parent août c'est
carrément le partenaire de vie donc
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui va qui
va durer puis qui qui va qui va changer
complètement une vie contrairement une
fac une fraction aussi d'un bras ou
d'une jambe on voit pas le this is it
c'est l'intérêt d'une fracture qui est
interne ce qui fait que souvent ces gens
là ont beaucoup de
difficulté à être reconnu puis à faire
reconnaître leurs erreurs lors de leurs
difficultés
cet ensemble c'est quelle réelle mais
qui peuvent être invisible qui sont
invisibles exactement parce que comme
moi par exemple après moi mon tcc
j'aurais de la difficulté que la
luminosité difficultés à écouter la télé
même si c'est vous que j'ai de l'intérêt
qu'on diminue bois etc a regardé mon
téléphone est trop difficile pour mes
yeux c'est quelque chose qui est
sournois quand qu'on ait de la
difficulté nécessairement chiffrés ou à
quantifier c'est pour ça que c'est
important pour les gens de consulter de
faire rapidement à travers le québec il
ya treize organismes un peu partout dans
chaque région et mieux évidemment de cet
internet qui le point de rencontre
connexion tcc qc une arme au poing c'est
que les gens peuvent consulter parce que
bon un accident de la route peut créer
un tcc mais y'a d'autres causes beaucoup
plus fréquentes je pense que c'est de
tomber tout simplement une chose d'être
agressés ou et les stéréotypes qui fixe
et de pensée est faut absolument
cotation un gros chagrin grosse
président de thau comme moi mais c'est
faux 66% des ddt ccjm de petites choses
et vulgaire chute comme par exemple
quelqu'un qui va monter sur une étagère
pour bouger quelque chose ou quelqu'un
qui s'en va faire une randonnée pédestre
en campagne qui engendre dans une racine
ou dans une roche qui se cogne la tête
c'est pour ça qu'il faut être très
vigilante parce que on pense pas à ça
dans nos déplacements
non ce droit souvent invincible mais on
n'est pas invincible il faut respecter
nos les trêves et ans puis vous pendant
votre convalescence mais vous avez quand
même pu réussir à écrire vous avez
écrites tout un album pendant votre
convalescence
une chance que je reste parce que moi je
suis quelqu'un de très actif
je fais des marathons je suis quand même
assez sportif mon mari mon médecin m'a
dit tout arrêter je te celle où je lirai
fou je m'arrache les cheveux puis il me
restait
reste heureusement l'écriture non quoi
j'ai j'ai écrit l'album le long chemin
qui menait le groupe qui m'a aidé à me
relever pour pas dire à me soulever
effectivement noah et vous parlais tout
à l'heure vous disiez lumineux que vous
aviez de la difficulté avec la lumière
je pense que c'est le qualificatif qui
est beaucoup ressorti d'ailleurs de ce
nouvel album que vous avez lancé en
terminant je veux vous lancer un mot
concernant la pandémie parce que je
voyais vous aviez des spectacles dont un
cette semaine qui était prévu finalement
s'est remis à l'année prochaine
why effectivement il ya beaucoup de
facteurs qui sont remis de la pandémie
on respecte les règles la santé publique
en or de revoir depuis défi car il était
capable d'en donner 3 on en restait des
spectacles gillett
parce que bon il y ont réouvert
doucement et j'ai eu moi j'aime
transformer le négatif en positif
donc je me suis construit un studio à la
maison depuis six mois j'ai écrit des
nouvelles chansons fait que après la
pandémie y aura un printemps l'an 2000
28e je vais lancer un nouvel album donc
on l'a jeu faut continuer à travailler
par contre la mise après la pandémie
aura un printemps gems en hollande ça et
puis on rappelle le site web aussi
concernant le pcc le traumatisme cranio
cérébral pour lequel vous êtes
ambassadeur merci beaucoup nicola
ciccone d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
merci à vous beau nationale 1 rousset